at a glance death loop arcane's newest
game might seem familiar to the studio's
previous games dishonored and prey but
death loop introduces new wrinkles to
the arcane formula that might be
initially challenging to wrap your head
around fret not though as we've
collected some of the lessons we wish we
knew before diving into the groundhog
days of black reef for more on death
loop make sure to like this video and
subscribe
death loop takes a while to really let
you loose on the island of black reef
slowly introducing you to all its
mechanics as it ferries you between its
four main districts at each stop you're
reminded that you'll have plenty of time
to return to these areas and not to
stress about seeing everything right now
you should heed this advice especially
since you won't be able to keep anything
you find because you won't be able to
infuse your gear with residum so
basically any hours you might have spent
scouring each district beforehand will
be wasted yes you might have built a
good mental map of each district ahead
of time but you'll soon realize that the
introduction of all the visionaries
death loops eight bosses change
everything anyway so pay attention to
death loop's tutorial but don't feel
stressed about seeing everything from
the get-go
just like dishonored you'll get access
to several supernatural abilities that
really inject a sense of playfulness to
death loop's first-person action unlike
dishonored however you'll need to steal
these powers from some of the deadliest
enemies on black reef this should be one
of your first priorities when you're
free to explore the island at will since
it will give you a big advantage with
pretty much everything to come two of
the best slabs to aim for in the early
game are shift and nexus shift lets you
teleport short distances in all
directions which cracks open the
platforming possibilities you have when
navigating each of the four districts
it's like learning to run after walking
and you'll likely struggle to find a
reason to replace it in your arsenal
once you have it nexus is like
dishonored 2's domino ability letting
you link together enemies and have them
share the fates of anyone in the group
here the ability is an area of effect
grenade that you can throw from quite
far away letting you set up group kills
from a safe distance once linked if you
kill one person in the group they'll all
go down which can seriously help clean
out some pesky patrols around important
objectives
just like weapons slabs aren't kept from
one loop to the next if you don't infuse
them that's why it's just as important
to get to the safety of the tunnels once
you've acquired a new one so that you
can keep it for your next big run these
infusions are some of the most expensive
in death loop 2 which might make it
difficult to infuse all the ones you
find during a particularly productive
run the first thing you should spend
your collected residueum on should be
new slabs since you'll want to have
access to them in any subsequent runs
and considering how difficult they can
be to obtain the high 10 000 residual
cost is well worth it every time this
applies to all slab upgrades you'll find
two since those are separate from each
slab and need to be equipped to each one
once acquired visionaries that drop
specific slabs will drop upgrades for
them once you've infused the base one
making repeated hunts of the same
targets worthwhile to further enhance
your supernatural arsenal
before long you'll start gathering loads
of residueum that you can spend on
weapons slabs upgrades and more between
your escapades in districts but while
you should be using it to infuse items
you might find useful you should take
notes of ones that you'll get at the
start of each run regardless of whether
they're infused or not this applies to
two items in particular your starting
sub machine gun and a character perk
that gives you a double jump these are
in your inventory at the start of every
run so don't bother wasting precious
residual infusing them in fact if you
can live without a double jump you can
make 2 000 residual early in a new run
by sacrificing it
this is one of those mistakes you make
only once but it can prevent you from
having a run end prematurely in the most
embarrassing ways around black reef you
can hack all manner of electrical
devices from security cameras to
automated turrets these turrets will
engage any enemies that are attacking
you once they've been hacked which can
be great for setting up ambushes or
turning the tide on a skirmish that
initially started poorly you can find
many of these turrets packed up in their
suitcase from around black reef letting
you set them up in your own way for some
strategic advantage just be warned that
you must hack them first too otherwise
as soon as you set them up they will
immediately turn around and gun you down
quite frequently you'll have your main
antagonist juliana invade your game
which immediately makes whatever
district you're picking apart much more
dangerous she's an incredibly powerful
foe with numerous abilities and top tier
weapons that can cut you down in the
blink of an eye when controlled by
another player too she's even more
deadly well most of the time the
conundrum then is that juliana also has
incredible gear she'll always drop a
rare weapon and a slab if you manage to
take her down saving you the time of
having to hunt down another visionary
and potentially improving your offensive
arsenal in surprising ways juliana also
only has one life while you can have
three if you've been careful cult's
reprisability lets you die twice in a
district before the loop resets giving
you three chances to take down juliana
use him wisely though as her ability to
adopt the appearance of any other npc
makes her pretty difficult prey to track
listen juliana is tough and she'll often
arrive to crash your party at the worst
time possible sometimes you're already
making your way to the tunnels to take
stock and infuse new gear you found and
suddenly juliana locks the tunnels until
you've confronted her thing is you don't
have to get violent to get access back
to your safe house if you don't fancy a
brawl try to stealth your way past her
defenses hack the dish and get out of
dodge before she finds you
you might be tempted to always hunt down
a visionary with every chance you get
but your progress through death loop
will benefit from occasionally taking a
break there are advantages to exploring
a district that doesn't have a target in
it just to scope out how the district in
question changes with the time of day
while also picking it apart for extra
residual killing enemies for trinket
drops and maybe finding a dormant secret
tucked away in a corner this can get
lost when you're laser focused on a
visionary so the freedom of not having
to worry about their demise can be
liberating
deathloop wants you to succeed and as
such gives you a lot of information
that's collected in your growing web of
leads to pursue most of them are
straightforward providing you with
waypoints to follow in districts and
hints as to how to draw out visionaries
in ways that might expose their
weaknesses but there are times when
you're expected to figure things out on
your own you can miss the minutia of
these puzzles if you don't take the time
to gather your bearings and consult the
notes you've gathered for each of the
leads on each visionary it's worthwhile
zooming out on your growing board of
information to get a sense of the
greater picture forming between the
smaller discoveries you've made which
will help you decide on the next best
course of action it's also wise to
pursue both visionary and slab leads
early on as you can effectively complete
two objectives with one venture into a
district plan each venture carefully and
you'll cut down the number of loops you
need to complete blackreef's puzzle
significantly
make sure to check out our 10 out of 10
review by tamur hussein right here on
our youtube channel or read it on
gamespot.com for more death loop make
sure to like this video and subscribe
and we'll catch you next time just
remember if all else fails carnesis is
your friend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
you